والمزيد معنا من الخرطوم شهاب الطيب
المتحدث الرسمي لقوى الحريه والتغيير
المجلس المركزي اهلا بك استاذ شهاب هل لك
ان تعطينا قراءتكم للمشهد الان وماذا
تتوقعون
طيب السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
في احتفال انه الان ان احنا نكاد يعني
اتمنى اسبوعين لا زالت يعني رغم الهدنه
الهشه هنالك اشتباكات في اعتقادنا انه
الاطراف الان هي بتحاول انه تحسن اوضاعها
على الارض طرفين المتقاتلين لكن ده برضو
ما حيمنع اننا نحن نتحرك في اتجاه دفع
الطرفين الى يعني
والتزام
يعني بالحوار لانهاء هذه الازمه لا يمكن
قبل ان ادخل طيب الا بالحوار ولكن قبل ان
ادخل بقضيه الحوار وقبولهم لذلك عندما
تقول انه الطرفين يحاولان تحسين اوضاعهما
على الارض انت ترمي على انه ذلك ربما يشي
بان هناك
تفاوضات وقبول للمفاوضات القادمه ولكن
الكل يريد الورق الاقوى ميدانيا لفورد
عليها ام ماذا
وبالواضح طبعا لطالما انه طلبته قراءه
للمشهد لانه نحن على تواصل برضه مع مع
اطراف دوليه ومع الله مع بعض الاطراف من
العسكريين في الداخل
للنقاش معهم حول يعني ما يمكن ان يتم من
تفاوض لانهاء هذه الازمه بالتالي هم ابدوا
الموافقه وهذا معلوم بالتالي نعتقد انه
الان ما يدور لطالما انه الطرفين وافقوا
على الحوار يبقى استمرار المعارك واضح انه
هو لتحسين الموقف على الارض
ان هناك قبول للحوار وبالمقابل هناك
تصريحات واضحه وصريحه ان كان من الجيش
فيما يتعلق
والبرهان تحديدا عندما يقول بانه لن يتحدث
ولا يفاوضتي
وبالمقابل حمتي يقول بانه يريد ان يحاكم
بالنهايه البرهان كيف يستوي هذا معدنك
وبواضح انه برضو كله طرف بيعاني من ضغوط
سوى كانت داخليه او كانت يعني ناتجه من
التورط في هذه الحرب العباسيه بالتالي
اللغه بتاعه يعني الخطاب السياسي او
الخطاب الاعلامي للطرفين بعض الاحيان يكون
خطاب نازح اتجاه الحوار وبعض الاحيان
يتحول الى خطاب برضه
للتماسك
المؤيدين او للتماسك الجنود على على الارض
بالتالي نسمع بعض الاحيان
الخطابات يقوم فيها لهجه تصعيديه طبيعي في
في حاله بتاعه حرب القبول الذي نستشعره
للتفاوض على ماذا واي مبادره هي الاقرب
ربما ان كان لدينا اي تفاصيل حولها
وطبعا الان ما تقدم رسميا هو الايجاد
ونعتقد انه الجميع كل الاطراف بتسعى
لايقاف الحرب هي مبادرات نعتقد انها ممكن
تدفع الاطراف تجاه الحل لانه اي طرف يتقدم
بين مبادره وهو مؤكد عنده الامكانيه اقناع
الاطراف او امكانيه الضغط على الاطراف
للجلوس لمفاوضات ايضا هنالك وضع لا نستطيع
ان نتجاهله هو الوضع الانساني القائمه
الان في السودان وبرضه يشكل للاطراف
المتصارعه او المتحاربه ضغط اضافي رغما عن
التجاوزات التي تتم لكن على المستوى
السياسي يمكن والدول والاقليمي يشكل ضغط
على اطراف الصراع في السودان
ليس اخلاقي سيد شهاب هذا ما تقوله من قبل
الطرفين
لطالما انه كل الحروب التي تدارت تدور في
العالم لا يمكن ان يتم فيها تجاوز بضرب
المرازق الصحيه والتعليميه ولا يمكن ان لا
تكون هنالك مسارات يعني يعني الانسانيه
لخروج المواطنين او حتى يعني لتلقي
الاسعافات الان حتى الان هنالك جثث في
سيارات في الشوارع نتيجه للضرب لا يستطيع
ان يتم مواد هذه الجثث او التعرف على
اصحابها هنالك
مدنيين يعني مصابين لا يمكن المستشفيات
خاليه كلها هذا الوضع نعتقد انه هو يمكن
ان يكون
اوفق توصيف لهذه الحرب انها هي
في ادنى سقوفه الاخلاقيه والتزامه المهني
للقوات يمكن ان تحمي تحمي المواطنين
لا يمكن ان يتم التعدي على المرافق الصحيه
وضرب وسط المواطنين بم
دارس باي شكل من اشكال الاسلحه التي لا
يمكن ان تستخدم داخل المدن
طيب حضرتك ذكرت انه المبادره الاساسيه
التي يمكن ان تكون فاعله هي مبادره ايجاد
لدينا تفاصيل عن هذه المبادره وطبيعه
التسويه التي يمكن ان تصل وهل يمكن للمكون
المدني ان يقبل بهذين الرجلين بعدما حدث
ت
اطلاق النار ومن
ثم حوار لكن هي لم تطرح تفاصيل دقيقه لما
يمكن ان يتم التوافق عليه هي فقط تحدثت عن
ان يتم اولا ايقاف
ايقاف دائم لاطلاق النار باليه مراقبه ومن
ثم جلوس الاطراف لتسويه الصراع الدائر ما
بين الدعم السريع والقوات المسلحه بالتالي
يمكن هو ده كل
العنوان العريض والتفاصيل التي وردت من
مبادره الايجاد واعتقد انه هي لمزيد من
استكشاف مواقف الاطراف لفت رئيس جمهوريه
جنوب السودان وجمهوريه جيبوتي
والرئيس الكيني بالحضور للسودان ولكن حتى
الان لم يتسنى لهم الحضور
يمكن هم تحدثوا بدواعي ضمانات امنيه لكن
هنالك اعتقد الان لطالما انه مطار وادي
سيدنا العسكري الان يستقبل طائرات
مواطنين الدول الاخرى كان بامكانها رؤساء
هذه الدول الحضور من خلال اي منفذ يعني
للتحدث حول لقاء طرفي النزاع طيب سننتظر
حتى يتم ذلك ولكن عندي سؤال فيما يتعلق
بالمكون المدني ما الذي يفعل الان او
تفعلوه انتم الان تحضيرا لاي اتفاقيه يمكن
ان يتوصل اليها الرجلان
اين هو ترتيب البيت الداخلي اذا ما صح
التعبير مما يحدث الان
في اعتقادنا انه معظم المبادرات
الاقليميه والدوليه هي كانت بتنطلق من من
المسؤوليه التي تتحملها القوه المدنيه
الموقع على الاتفاظ الاطار وفي الاساس هو
الحريه والتغيير هي يعني من بادرت
بالتواصل مع الاليه الثلاثيه والرباعيه
وكذلك الاتحاد الافريقي ولا ننسى انه
هنالك يعني من القوى الموقعه مسؤولين
حكوميين سابقين قبل انقلاب 25 اكتوبر وهم
عندهم حتى الان تواصل مع قاده الدول في
الاقليم تواصلوا معها كمثال رئيسه الوزراء
رئيسه وزيره الخارجيه السابقه دكتوره مريم
الصادق جميعهم على تواصل كذلك قيادات
الاخرى من قوه الحريه والتغيير هم من
بادروا حتى الهدنه الاولى التي استمرت
التي كانت اربع ساعات هي كانت بمباركه من
القوه المدنيه
دور جميل ولكن ماذا عن التوحد في المواقف
ويجب ان تكون هناك جبهه قويه الان بحال تم
التوصل الى اي اتفاق مع المكونين
انكم انتم تكونوا متابعين ما يدور في في
الساحه المدنيه في السودان هنالك اول امس
تم اطلاق جبهه مدنيه
لايقاف الحرب والسعاده الديمقراطيه ذهب
نداء شامل سيد شهاب اسمح لي هذا نداء شامل
وبالاصل كان هناك توحد في المواقف وفجاه
اختلفت الاراء والرؤى في مستقبل السودان
وبالتالي السؤال الان الى اي حد بالفعل
هناك قوه قادره على ان تكون فارضه لنفسها
بحال وجوب التفاوض ما بين الاطراف
يعتقد انه الاساس بتاع الجبهه المدنيه
لايقاف الحرب واستعاده الديمقراطيه لها
يعني في بيانه تاسيسه لها قضايا واضحه هي
تتعامل مع الواقع الجديد الذي انتجه يعني
انتجهوا هذا الصراع المسلح ويمكن ان هذه
الجبهه تطور من من اليه تعملها
لان تقلد جبهه عريضه قادره انها تفرض
الرؤيه السياسيه لكن خلينا نكون اكثر
واقعيه الان الاولويه هي ايقاف الحرب ومن
ثم العوده لمسار العمليه السياسيه لانه
هذه العمليه السياسيه هي وضعت معالجه
لموضوع تعدد الجيوش وبالتالي اذا كان تم
التوقيع النهائي يمكن كان ان نتدارك لحد
كبير هذا الصراع المسلح لانه هذا الصراع
المسلح هو النتيجه لتعدد الجيوش بالتالي
عمليه السياسيه او الحل السياسي قدم حل
لهذا الوجود من التعدد من القوات المتعدده
سواء كانت دعم سريعه او حركات مسلحه او
حتى
والمكون المدني تعدد الاوجه والخطابات
ايضا حملت بعض المسؤوليه ولكن على كل
نتمنى التوفيق للجبهه الجديده من الخرطوم
شهاب الطيب المتحدث الرسمي لقوى الحريه
والتغيير المجلس العسكري شكرا جزيلا لك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات